welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier gave us its first official
teaser during the Superbowl in a kind of
Marvel on Disney Plus spot that also
teased bonkers looks at whan division
and Loki and we're gonna talk about long
division and Loki and other videos but
here we're just gonna focus on Falcon
Winter Soldier because there is plenty
to talk about from these 15 or so
seconds rock stars we see a couple
frames of cap shield and find like a
million things to say about it time just
more slowly for us we're like sonic we
also have a million things to say about
that little martyr anyway spoiler
warning Agusta predict anything to
accurately and ruin your life let's
start with the first footage shows caps
shield wedged in the tree before being
yanked out by its new bearer Sam Wilson
Falcon pulled cap handed off to Sam in
the final moments of Avengers in-game
with an approving nod from Bucky and
that nod should be enough for those of
you who believe that Bucky not Sam
deserves to carry that shield and if the
nod isn't enough keep in mind that
depending on how you interpret the
timeline logic at the end of endgame old
cap could have lived his life in an
alternate history created by its
decision to stay in the past with Peggy
now this is all under dispute but in
games directors have maintained that
they believe cap created a new branch
timeline that played out off-screen and
then he jumped back to this prime
timeline to hand off the shield the
screenwriters and others that suggested
that old cap actually lived within this
same timeline even though that raises
all kinds of confusing questions about
Peggy's marriage and cap standing by as
horrible historical tragedies unfolded
worst of those tragedies being capped
making out with his grandniece the
reason I bring this up is if you believe
the directors alternate history
explanation cap could have already
handed off the shield to Bucky in that
alternate timeline a story that we might
still see someday and perhaps now after
that story cap has realized that it's
more important for Sam to carry the
shield in the way endgame left things in
this universe the legacy of Captain
America appears to be the key theme of
this series with the government ponying
out a doppelganger so perhaps old cap
wants the worthy a soldier he could
imagine rallying the public to the truth
and that is veteran counselor Sam Wilson
not globally hated assassin Bucky Barnes
now Sam here is practicing caps old move
the backhand frisbee playing but where
is he that appears to be some kind of
home maybe like Tony Stark circle
importance but notice that Spanish
hanging from the trees that typically
grows in the American South Stark's
farms in New York Barton's farms in
Missouri some have suggested that this
farm looks similar to the Rambo home in
Louisiana in Captain Marvel operated by
Maria Rambo in the 90s and now
presumably by Monica Rambeau her
daughter Monica Rambeau has been
announced to appear in one division but
not this series as of yet also Sam's
house here is blue two stories with a
railing on the porch the Rambo house was
smaller and gray so perhaps this could
be Sam Wilson's family's southern home a
place where he and Bucky can stay off
the grid while still fugitives from
their defiance of the sokovia accords
and Civil War maybe old man cap can also
crash here as a retired mentor guy in
the chair of this base of operations and
probably also a shitty roommate my
grandniece didn't have to pay rent cuz
she's sharing my bed mm-hmm this being
Sam's ancestral home might also explain
what exactly he's doing here now it
could be practicing frisbee and
destroying the property's trees like how
to anger at some tragic history that
still haunts him like Jenny and her
southern home sometimes are just hot
enough cap shields but before he
continued this extra little bounce in my
step that you've been seeing
well it's thanks to me unloading some
junk in my trunk and don't get any gross
ideas I'm talking about a wallets a real
old man wallet that I had to carry
around with me everywhere was giving me
back trouble but no longer thanks to our
good friends the ridge who sponsored
this episode the ranch makes every day
good to the standard you don't see every
day they streamline their life by
turning the things you carry like
backpacks and chargers and wallets and
the tools for a better living their
flagship product is the ridge wallets it
was launched on Kickstarter 2013 and now
sits in the front pockets of over half a
million men and women that old wallet I
talked about it was filled with like
membership cards and coupons grocery
lists love poems that no longer define
me this is their aluminum wallet in the
raw color they have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
something for everyone really this one's
for me it's liked it's strong and is a
cool industrial chic vibe the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wallet that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day it has 30,000 five-star
reviews there's a better way to carry
your caching cards there's a lifetime
warranty if you love it three returns if
you don't it comes a titanium carbon
fire aluminum and over a dozen different
styles of colors they also have great
backpacks and
travel bags with RFID blocking pockets
and optional device charging batteries
get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping in returns by going to Ridge
comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and these the code new rock stars final
link in the video's description let's
move on next we get some wild aerial
shots showing wingsuit gliding I wonder
if this will be part of some kind of
freefall fight like the one with Keanu
and Swayze Point Break
now it's hard to tell but the gun man
here whoops colleague Daniel Bruhl as
helmet Zemo who's returning to this
series after home-wrecking the Avengers
and Civil War based on the teaser at
Comic Con it looks like Zima will wear
his purple mask from the comics there's
also a shot of Falcon flying through a
canyon wings are still on so in addition
to carrying the shield he's also gonna
keep the wings which makes sense he
doesn't have the Super Soldier Serum he
meets all the tech he can get next
there's a shot of Bucky cleaned up nice
aiming a gun at Zemo and then there's a
close-up as emo as bullets or dropped to
the ground in front of him now I'm
guessing this is from a different moment
because Bucky's hold the gun with his
right hand but then on the shot his emo
is his new vibranium arm in hand
dropping the bullets port there's just
like a handoff going on anyway the last
we saw of Zemo he got arrested by
T'Challa at the end the Civil War and
ended up in Ross's custody he's
threatened with electroshock if you ever
escaped perhaps the events of the blip
could have freed him from that prison
like maybe the prison guards dusted away
or Zemo himself could have dusted away
but then returned to his containment
cell now and we know that Falco Winter
Soldier will be sent in a deliberately
post blip world there was a set photo
with a sign reading samson development
rebuilding your city after the blip and
if Bucky is unwilling to kill Zemo here
perhaps this suggests a team up between
Bucky and Zemo should be a lot of water
under that bridge because you know Zemo
framed Bucky for lots of murders but
maybe Bucky's frustrated that Sam is
carrying the torch he thinks you should
carry and then decides to take up Zemo
on an offer to join a league of
misunderstood outlaws similar to a
Thunderbolts theory I had pitched in
previous videos go check him out but on
to the last clip we're back ok
we're at a football game with a marching
band fireworks dancers and a new map
this is actually John Walker
u.s. agent aka the villain super Patriot
played here by Wyatt Russell Walker was
introduced as the government's
incarnation of Captain America to
replace Steve Rogers Captain America and
this could explain why he's being
paraded here as this kind of Boy Scout
poster boy as Steve Rogers was as a PR
tool for the war effort in the forties I
am guessing this will create a conflict
between Wilson the successor cap chose
and Walker the successor Ross in the
government want you can see the Walker
has a newly designed logo and a with the
wings really emphasized in the America
of Captain America even more strongly he
does carry a shield but it's not clear
if this is the true cap vibranium shield
were just part of a costume and lastly
Sam and Bucky appear in some facility
hallway maybe the location Zima was last
seen that's only a few frames but
there's definitely some tension here
could be some shield nd or based on
Mackey and Stan Connick on either way
comment down below with your thoughts on
this teaser and stay tuned for separate
videos on one division the other Marvel
updates we got during the Superbowl
coming very soon follow me Eddie a vas
follow new rock stars on social media
subscribe to new rock stars for all of
our Marvel theories thanks for watching
bye
[Music]